y realmente dentro del manejo de los
factores de riesgo tenemos dos grandes
grupos toda la parte genética toda la
parte de la carga hereditaria que
podemos tener pero asimismo sabemos que
el cáncer es una enfermedad
multifactorial es decir va de la mano de
una vida sana de decirle no al
sedentarismo y de no consumir tabaco ni
alcohol porque sabemos que estos
factores de riesgo se pueden sumar a los
genéticos y esto nos puede llevar a
desencadenar un cáncer de mama sabemos
también que la pandemia nos ha traído
grandes consecuencias y seguramente no
hemos visto los números que
probablemente van a aumentar dado que la
disminución en las consultas para hacer
las mamografías y los exámenes que el
examen clínico de mama pueden disminuyó
de una forma muy grande por la selección
colombia se diagnosticaron 15 mil 500
casos nuevos y hubo 4 mil 400 muertes en
el año 2020 por esta enfermedad